[Music]
so this tattoo means a lot to me because
it it's like based off of two stuffed
animals that
a friend had given me and the person i
was dating at the time so they had the
panda and i had the giraffe to ask my
favorite animal like i consider myself a
giraffe and i like took this picture of
the giraffe kissing the panda and i do
like to think that like somewhere
giraffe and panda are happy forever like
so i know it's like it's so bittersweet
because
you know love can hurt but i think
somewhere they're like happy together
so that's my tattoo
[Music]
they're both kind of related okay
so they're both from my grandpa who was
like the lifeline of our family um so
this is actually on the back of my neck
his maiden name because
he only had two daughters so there's no
one else to carry on the name kramer
and then during the cold war he was in
the air force and actually spoke morris
code and would listen in on russian
radio
and translate morris code
so
that's what the morse code is for and it
says i love you and i like you because
he would always tell us that you have to
love your family but you don't have to
like him so when he told us i love you
and i like you we knew he meant it
so when i was 17 i graduated high school
and
we went to maui and we decided to get
tattoos and i just wanted across them
but i didn't know what i wanted so i got
it's across fast forward like six years
later i'm in my senior year college
and my roommate who was an international
student from taiwan she's like what's on
your wrist i said oh it's a tattoo she's
like can i see it she i said yeah so she
takes a look at it and she starts
laughing i was like what's so funny she
was like it means rice and mandarin
i thought it was just a cross but
apparently now everybody knows that i
have rice tattooed on my wrist
that's the only tattoo i ever got after
that
so like you like looked through the
pictures and you thought you were
picking a cross yeah and it was really
rice and mandarin
so if i'm ever in a country that only
speaks mandarin and i'm hungry
it's tattooed on my wrist
it says where is the babysitting money
it's in my grandpa's handwriting my
grandpa just passed last year and it was
something that i found when we were
cleaning out the house because my
grandma used to babysit and i babysit
i think i also use my babysitting money
to pay for it
the way it's worded where and the fact
that he just wrote a note is very kind
of like telling of their relationship i
always knew my grandpa loved my grandma
more
and i feel like the fact that like
he would like write these notes even if
it's like insignificant i wanted to kind
of like immortalize the fact that he
would write notes to her my grandma
passed hers and i think my grandpa
passed from a broken heart because it
was like once she passed he just didn't
care to take care of himself anymore can
i plug my artist because i go to the
same artist yes all the time okay his
name's colin and his instagram is
something in the sewer um when i was
younger i was pretty isolated from my
sister and my stepdad because i was
really sensitive and they like to make
those those types of jokes that aren't
made for sensitive kids so i always kind
of took it bad when they called me a
crybaby but one time i was alone and
i worded on my wrist and i was like you
know what i'm going to take some pride
in it so i got some tattooing and a
needle and did a stick and poke
you did it yourself yeah this is my only
tattoo it's a stick and poke that i got
in new york four years ago she thought
stick and pokes were temporary yes so
she was wrong on them they're not
pointer i was 16
um it was friday the 13th i just wanted
to go for it
and they told me it's only the last like
four months it's been so long
i've had it for so long and my dentist
hates me for it so
honestly my best friend one of my best
friends at time we're walking through uh
pb
and we're
he was feeling for a tattoo so i asked
him
what kind of tattoo do you want and he
said you know what i've always wanted a
camel on my tab now that's like dude
let's do it it was his first tattoo and
we did it
60 bucks later i got a camel on my
so what's the story behind your tattoo
um i just love flowers ooh
it's kind of my garden
and then yeah it's a vibe
that's cool that you call it your garden
yeah because i'm gonna grow a whole uh
it's going to continue in my life
because i have some right there too you
know how it takes water to grow an
actual garden
what does it take to grow the flowers
the garden on youtube
that is such a good question um it used
to be anger because i'm very impulsive
so something made me angry i was like i
need to go get tatted and then i started
to realize that shouldn't be the reason
so now it's forgiveness is my water for
my sleep so once i forgive myself for
going through that situation and took
the lesson then i get tatted now so it's
not an impulsive decision now so like
forgiveness is the water to my garden
so it's a snapdragon vine and the street
that i grew up on was snapdragon away at
the house that i lived on and that
street um i endured
a lot of verbal abuse from my stepmom
and my dad never like stood up for me i
ended up getting kicked out and never
talking to my dad ever again so now i
got this to symbolize like growth from
that trauma i don't know i just
like want to remind myself that like
you can grow from things that you've
like endured
okay well so my little brother died um
well he's born with a heart defect and
that's how he died and so i wanted to
get something to commemorate him and
then i had a friend that was an artist
and he was super talented and he was
just a really really good person but he
was also struggling with like mental
health and substance abuse so anyway i
asked him to draw this and then he ended
up overdosing whilst working on that and
a bunch of other things and so my
brother's initials were right here and
his initials were right there so now
when you look down at the tattoo what
feelings does it give you
so i'm a really fidgety person so i like
touching it and it makes me feel happy
because especially like just running my
fingers over my little brother's
initials one i think you think it's cool
so just like the fact that it's like
tactical a little bit it's raised on my
skin i don't know it's like a more
realistic sense that he's somewhere or
just his memories there so it just makes
me happy because it's for him
it's a paper clip i was in the navy and
they love to use acronyms so i got an
acronym my first day out my first
veterans day out of the military it
means paper clip people against people
ever reenlisting civilian life is
preferred
paper clip
and then when you look down at your
tattoo what feeling does it give you
freedom
everybody has different experiences with
the military but mine was just like
not awesome but like not bad either but
it's expensive you know
is there a story behind your tattoos
um no i just like it it's badass you
just like the way they look yeah
basically that's really cool so what got
you started
um actually this one got me started i
like this koi fish and then
it was just kind of from there
i just kept building on it and building
on it and now we're here this is my
favorite one but it's hard to pull on my
pants right now
why is that your favorite because it's
so wicked like with the head cut off and
everything i actually got tattooed down
the street right here wait do you want
to shout out you're the tattoo artist
yeah his name is pete vodka full circle
tattoo what's up pete this one
is because i'm always torn between my
heart and my brain so
just and i also work in healthcare so
anatomy is kind of like a big part of my
job in my life and then my mouth is to
always look for the light because moths
are always searching for light oh that's
so cool yeah i love you
yeah that's mine aren't as cool as his
but i i like them i think every tattoo
is cool
yeah how'd you guys be uh
did you guys connect through your
tattoos
she likes she has a type i do have a
type
is it tattoos yeah
beards and tattoos that's my type
of personality
yeah she liked me for my physical
[Music]
you